the david pakman show subreddit at david
pakman.com slash our EDD IT now has
nearly 13,000 of our viewers and
listeners participating in political
discussion and suggesting ideas for the
show a couple of things that caught my
eye this morning a very interesting post
saying hey David can you interview crazy
people again some of your best material
online is the classic interviews with
the anti-gay religious crowd I think I
heard you say times are different now
and there'd be no point in interviewing
these people I beg you though please at
least once a month interview a loonie
I'm up for this you know really the
problem we've been having is we're
having a hard time finding loonies that
are number one able to be coherent
enough that you can even have like a
conversation because with a lot of these
folks you just introduce them and then
it's 20 minutes of ranting and raving
and we just get nowhere and also finding
ones that are that are sort of even
mildly relevant so if there are
particular extremists or wacky folks
that you want me to interview I am more
than willing to do some of those
interviews like we used to do on the
show it's just a matter of finding the
right people let me know who you think
might meet the minimum criteria for me
to do that but we're more than glad to
book those folks on the show if you
don't want me to do that also let me
know that would be interesting to hear
another post linking to cold James
Cash's appearance on the Jesse Lee
Peterson show I this might be inside
baseball and if it is I apologize but
Jesse Lee Peterson is a pro Trump
anti-black Pro white black conservative
whose program I appeared on in Los
Angeles when I was there six months ago
or so seven eight months now nine months
maybe Wow
time flies and he recently interviewed
an individual named Col James cash I
don't really want to spoil anything
about the appearance for you but let me
just say this
you should watch all of it and it's
under two minutes long because the guy
got kicked off much like I've previously
been kicked off of Jesse Lee Peterson's
show so check that out and you can find
it on the David Pakman show
subreddit at david pakman.com slash our
EDD IT help us get to 13,000 subscribers
on the subreddit that would be
delightful